since time's a memorial people have been
dreaming about discovering worlds
similar to our own planet
today we're as close to it as we could
get
among the thousands of exoplanets
pinpointed beyond the solar system
dozens
are similar to the earth to this or that
extent
is there at least one that could
realistically become our second home
cosmo the first in outer space
the first exoplanets were discovered
back in the late 1980s
since then the number of detected ones
has increased hundredfold
according to statistics from january
over four thousand planets in other
systems have already been discovered
apart from these several thousand
candidates likely to be given the status
have been registered
with sufficient evidence from
earth-based observatories
most of them are going to become
officially confirmed exoplanets
the overall number of planets in our
galaxy may supposedly be
over one trillion from five to twenty
percent of these are close to our earth
in terms of their size and composition
not all of them are in their host stars
go deluxe zones
that is not all of them are habitable
still
according to scientific estimates there
are not less than 300 million
potentially habitable planets in the
milky way
exoplanets differ very much in terms of
their environment
their dimensions may be enormous some
even beating jupiter
but there are also comparatively smaller
ones close to our earth in size
some of these bodies are hot consumed
with oceans of molten lava
whereas others are encased in a shell of
permanent ice
there are planets out there made
entirely of oceans
with not a bit of dry land on them while
in others
sulfuric acid drains or diamond snow are
irregular occurrence
various techniques are used for
discovering other worlds
as a rule it is next to impossible to
spot an exoplanet by simply looking
through a telescope
that is why in 2009 kepler was launched
the first space telescope designed for
searching for planets beyond the
boundaries of the solar system
the telescope's cameras had 42
charge-coupled devices or ccds
with a total resolution of around 96
megapixels
with a field of view covering about 25
percent of the sky
and coupled with a one and a half meter
mirror of the telescope
it was able to detect astronomical
bodies within 3000 light years from the
earth
in the three and a half years of
productive operations
kepler managed to spot over three and a
half thousand
exoplanet candidates the status of over
two thousand of these
has already been confirmed by repeated
observations
it was in this period that the smallest
of known exoplanets today was detected
the diameter of kepler-37b is just
35.7 percent that of the earth
the telescope was also instrumental in
registering several stars and brown
dwarfs
the transit method was used by kepler in
the search for exoplanets
this method is based on observing the
star's luminosity
if the supposed planet passes between
the parent star and the observer
this will be noticed in the telltale
decrease in the star's luminosity
the extent of these fluctuations in
luminosity
directly depends on the ratio of the
stars and planets dimensions
while their regularity allows one to
estimate the object's orbital period
the transit method requires accuracy in
measurements
changes in a star's spectrum account for
less than two percent
and are usually tenths or even
hundredths of one percent
ripples in the atmosphere dust and
precipitations
negatively affect results produced by
earth-based telescopes
that is the reason why telescopes based
on automatic space stations are used for
searching for objects
beyond the boundaries of the solar
system
unfortunately in 2013 three and a half
years into the mission
the kepler space telescope had several
major equipment failures
in 2018 the spacecraft ended science
operations completely
kepler was the first spacecraft to be
created specifically for looking for
exoplanets
however most of the objects it managed
to spot happen to be too remote and dim
to study them in any satisfying detail
that is why the next space research
complex
had slightly different parameters kepler
was succeeded by the test telescope
launched by nasa on the 18th of april
its main object was searching for rocky
exoplanets
orbiting the brightest stars within 200
light years from the sun
this telescope also used the transit
method
and here is the spacecraft's brief
profile tess
is equipped with four refractors with a
24 by 24 degree
field of view and a 10 centimeter
aperture
the spacecraft's peculiar orbit allows
it to cover both the northern and the
southern parts of the sky
which is approximately 85 percent of the
entire sky
photos are taken by four cameras and the
resolution of each camera's ccd is 16.8
megapixels
toi 700d is one of the most
notable objects discovered by tess
this exoplanet became the first object
of the kind comparable to the earth and
size
and which found itself in the habitable
zone of its star
it orbits toi 700 a red dwarf lying
slightly over a hundred light years away
from the sun
it is a small and rather cold star its
temperature is half that of the sun
and its mass and radius are just 40
percent those of the sun
toi 700 is peculiar for its high
stability not a single flare
has been registered on it since the
beginning of observations
a star's stability is a positive feature
because bursts of activity are able to
divest its planets of their atmospheres
and be generally pernicious for
potential life on planet surfaces
there are at least three planets
orbiting toi 700
the one closest to it toi 700b
is comparable to the earth in size its
mass is approximately 1.07
times that of our planet and its radius
differs from that of the earth by not
more than 2 percent
unfortunately toi 700b is too close to
its host star
it is within about 0.06 astronomical
units
and a year on the planet lasts just 10
days
in addition to that chances are it is
tidally locked
that is it faces the star with one in
the same side
this means that the planet is likely to
be scorching hot
the planet lying further from its star
toi 700c
is thought to be a mini neptune its mass
may be from 5 to 13 times that of our
earth
and its radius is two or three times
that of the earth
it takes toi 700c 16 days to complete
one orbit around its host's star
located closer to the star than the
inner border of the habitable zone
it must be too hot for life to originate
and evolve there
toi 700d is the third
and at this point the remotest planet in
the system discovered by now
it takes 37.4 days to complete a full
orbit
which by the way lies along the inner
edge of the habitable zone
the mass of toi 700d hasn't been gauged
precisely
and may be anything from one to three
times that of the earth
at the same time the planet's radius is
just twenty to thirty percent bigger
than that of the earth
toi 700d is thought to be a rocky world
but its exact composition is not yet
known
the amount of energy received by the
planet from its star
is 86 that of the amount we receive from
the sun
assuming the planet's atmosphere is
similar to ours the steady state
temperature on the surface of toi 700d
is estimated at 268.8 kelvin
or 4.3 degrees celsius below zero
however due to the greenhouse effect or
other features of the atmosphere we may
not know yet
this figure may shift either up or down
there is no precise data on the
eccentricity of toi 700d
but it is thought to be small at around
0.11
as the planet's orbit finds itself at
the inner edge of the goldilocks zone
the planet's eccentricity however small
may incidentally turn out to be
perceptible when the planet comes too
close to its star from time to time
thus actually leaving the habitable zone
still with the year on the planet
lasting slightly over one earth month
such unfavorable periods are expected to
be rather
short if there are living creatures on
toi 700d
then they might be able to weather the
harsh spells in a state of anabiosis
alternatively they could adapt or
migrate to less inclement areas
even though the data acquired by
spectral analysis of toi 700d
can't be enough for making conclusions
there is a chance that there is liquid
water on the planet's surface
then there is bound to be the greenhouse
effect too
which will help the surface temperature
to reach favorable values
as i've already mentioned toi 700d
along with the other known planets in
the system is highly likely to be
tidally locked to its star
if this is the case there should be a
stark difference in temperatures between
the sunny side and the shadow side
this contrast could be leveled off by
dance atmosphere
but that would cause powerful hurricane
winds
although the main mission of tess has
been accomplished by now
it still has enough resources to carry
on operations
the telescope will continue taking
snapshots of the sky
including the milky way plane which is
the most challenging direction for
observation
over 2 100 exoplanet candidates have
been discovered by tess in the course of
the main mission
not less than 66 of them have already
been confirmed
apart from that six supernovae flares
have been registered
three exo comets identified and a great
number of photos
taken of small bodies in the solar
system the latters were not
objects of the main mission but are of
course of scientific interest
toi 700d is still guarding its mysteries
and waiting for its explorers
great hopes are placed on the new
orbital telescope james webb
which may help investigate this world
and a number of other ones
the new telescope is supposed to provide
images of not only exoplanets lying
closest
but also detect their moons and carry
out spectral analysis of their surfaces
the launch of the telescope is planned
for the 31st of october 2021.
if all goes according to plan first data
will be available as soon as next year
will we ever discover a world that could
rightfully be called the second earth
and if we do will we be able to reach it
distances in space are just too much for
humans
could it be that we're confined to the
limits of our system forever
allowed only to gaze at the vast
infinite universe
[Music]
you